this was when i was very overweight if i
didn't make it up to the top of the hill
i would be so disappointed in myself but
i have to go like
did i try did i do what i could do or
was i being lazy because there's a
place in there for those right if your
goal is to ride the tour de france
which i think is a really lofty goal you
know and obviously i'm not even talking
about professionally just go over and
ride stages from the tour of france
these are incredibly hard things to do
and you're down on yourself because on
day one of
training for this you can't make it up
to the top of the hill
it's like you got to be realistic about
what you're doing did you get up
did you get on your bike did you get
your ride in if that's all you needed to
do that day that's all you needed to do
right you don't start out by doing 100
miles
or you know looking at guys like david
goggins
it's like it can be daunting but you got
to realize like that's what that guy
does
what's your version of that